The answer is if we use Car.methods as the prototype for new instance, then
fell property look ups to those instances, we'll fall through to Car.methods.
And thus every instance will appear to have a .move method.
Even if we don't manually copy them over on this line.
That means, we can get rid of this line entirely.
We do still need to make sure this loc property gets added to our new object,
since it's no longer in line as part of an object literal.
We're instead using this object that creates syntax.
As of this change,
we've arrived at the completed prototypal pattern of writing your class.
This is not to be confused with the pseudo-classical pattern,
which is coming up next.